Speaker 1: All right, let's do a little let's
do almost like a history lesson type segment
here, I have an example for you today of something
that the modern Republican Party is now regularly
engaging in that is indistinguishable from
standard historical fascist propaganda.
It checks all the boxes today.
We're going to be comparing it specifically
to Italian fascist propaganda during and in
the pre Mussolini era.
It all makes sense in a moment.
Come along for the ride.
We will start with radical pro Trump, Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green's new
political advertisement.
Apparently, she's running in 2022.
We were we've been wondering how many of these
Trump will run in 2022 if they run, how many
of them are going to win?
It's going to be a big piece of influencing
whether or not Donald Trump runs in 2024.
Marjorie Taylor Green in her new ad says,
I guess if you reelect her, she's going to
blow away the Democrats socialist agenda.
And then in the video, she actually blows
up a car, a Prius with socialism on it, with
a 50 cal rifle that she is also auctioning
off for people who contribute to her campaign.
Like every aspect of this is just a dystopian
fascist propaganda piece.
Let's take a look at it and then we are going
to discuss.
OK, so here's the ad.
Speaker 3: See, Pelosi is sneaking the green
New Deal into the three point five trillion
dollar budget.
And in twenty twenty two, I'm going to blow
away the Democrats socialist agenda.
This is straight up fascist propaganda.
And it's it's potentially an incitement to
violence because she's normalizing shooting
socialist Preus.
Right.
I mean, it's it's not even an analogy.
She's shooting a socialist Prius in the car.
So we have a ton of examples of fascist propaganda.
This is just another example.
When you look for examples of the propaganda
of fascist Italy leading up to and during
the Mussolini era, it's this type of stuff.
I'm going to tell you the themes of this is
now these are the themes of Italian fascist
propaganda, very well known historically.
And look at how much it applies to Marjorie
Taylor, green number one personality cults
around individuals.
This is not Marjorie Taylor Greene talking
about policy.
This is Marjorie Taylor Green building a cult
of personality around her as a socialist gun
toter who blows up socialist prices, right?
That's what it is.
Action overtalk as a form of politics was
a theme of Italian fascist propaganda.
Marjorie Taylor Green shooting a gun at a
socialist car.
She's not talking about issues.
She's not talking about solving problems like
an adult.
She's using action overtalk as the default
of politics for.
OK, so now this one, because Marjorie Taylor
Green is a woman, we have to think a little
bit differently about this one.
But for Mussolini and Italian fascism, fertility
and the strength of men was a big thing.
This is kind of like a female version of it,
although there's not as direct of an analogy
of Marjorie Taylor Greene appearing to be
more likely to bear children on the basis
of shooting guns.
But there's also a bit of a masculinization
of Marjorie Taylor Greene.
So so maybe it does actually apply.
That's another one attacking foreign culture
in Italy.
It was Americanism that was attacked, French
and Russian literature were attacked, etc.
In this case with Marjorie Taylor Green, it's
the pseudo foreign culture of American socialists.
They're not foreigners.
But the idea is they aren't like us.
They're not really Americans in the mold that
we believe Americans should exist.
So very similar.
And then, of course, Italian fascist propaganda
was anti-democratic and it was anti small
L liberalism.
Shooting your political opponents is not Democratic.
This is again about firearms as solutions,
the use of slogans to cover the violence of
what you propose.
OK, that was a common thing at the eight second
mark in this video, which I will pull up for
you.
It says in twenty twenty two I'm going to
blow away the Democrats socialist agenda and
notice she blows up a Toyota Prius, a sort
of emblem of what they don't like.
Prius, one of the first hybrid vehicles now
available as a plug in car.
Even that detail is relevant to the fascistic
nature of the propaganda.
It's a fight for fossil fossil fuels.
We're not no silly hybrids or electric cars.
Now, that's the analysis with fascist propaganda
from Italy.
Just, you know, you could you could do it
with something else altogether.
But we've just picked that.
And our friend and fellow Argentinean Federico
Finkelstein, who is an expert on fascism,
actually tweeted in response to this video,
Fascist Propaganda 101.
We have to be calling this for what it is.
Lots of politicians blowing things up, Taliban
style to make political points about how bad
liberals are and how the left has to be punished.
And meanwhile, if you propose like a child
tax credit that's called socialist by these
very same people, they're disseminating actual
fascistic propaganda.
But if you want like health care for people
or a child tax credit or enhanced unemployment,
then you are you are called a socialist.
It's really dangerous stuff.
And unfortunately, if it's not sort of root
it out, it's going to increasingly become
more and more common that we see it.
Why?
Because they've even abandoned policy altogether.
Notice that there's no policy there.
There's no there's no it's just we're going
to block we're going to blow away the socialists
and block Nancy.
How does she pronounce it?
Pelosi, et cetera.
They're going to keep doing this type of stuff
unless somebody, somebody or something stops
them or unless it loses them elections because
they've given up on policy years ago.
We've talked about that before.